I already know when women say I'm  traditional in a sense it means I want  to be courted I want to know I want to  this is what they mean I want to be  courted like a traditional woman even  though I'm not one because I'm not a  virgin I'm not married before 25 I don't  have a cookbook oh but I cook one to two  times a week so yeah I'm traditional now  I'm like if you I swear to God if you  had a conversation with the actual real  traditional women oh my God and I I I've  been talking to them for this wife  school oh my God they run circles around  us they make all their meals from  scratch from scratch they've been  raising kids and in a kid's like  situations where they're in charge of  children since they're like 16. they've  been either babysitting this woman had  10 foster kids wow that's that's a real  traditional woman she's growing at her  garden in the backyard oh my God